my friends their band played at the nude
resort and so i tagged along to be nosey
when i got there i was instantly greeted
by tons of naked people
hey i'm linda and i've been a nudist for
10 years
this is how i got started i
had the invitation to meet with two of
my friends
and it was actually a surprise they
didn't tell me it was going to be a
naked beach
they said we were gonna be going to an
amusement park and we were
gonna be going to the beach so i packed
all my things i stayed overnight with
them
and then they surprised me and said it's
actually a naked beach
and so i had a moment where i had to
decide
if i wanted to do it and if i could do
it i decided i wanted to i was
interested in it
and so i was like i was going to go for
it i remember being afraid
being nervous i remember being worried
about what my friends would think of my
body
being worried about my hair situation so
the morning of
i made sure i shaved everything later i
realized that was not necessary
it was really exciting i loved it but i
was also nervous at the same time
and i actually remember uh texting my
boyfriend at the time in all caps like
i'm naked right now i was very
exhilarated by it all there was a guy
that had clothes on
who came up to us and he said oh i'm
nervous this is my first time being here
like
how did you do that like how do you do
this and so eventually he got naked and
we were able to coach him through it and
then i was hooked
[Music]
i have been a nudist now for
wow almost six years i was
always curious about it you know living
in south florida it's
been at the back of my mind you got the
southeast situation
i had no idea there was an actual nude
beach within
30 to 40 minute drive for me so as soon
as i found out i had to go and try it
i had looked online before i went
and i came across a woman who was
visiting from texas with her husband
and they were looking for someone local
to
meet them there at the beach hang out so
i met them there very nervous
i mean first of all meeting someone on
craigslist that i've never met before
not only that but at the nude beach
that was kind of weird to me
[Laughter]
they were really nice people they've
been nudists for a very long time
i was very nervous at first
about you know getting naked out in
public
other people around but you know once i
did it
drop my pants you look around no one's
looking
everybody's minding their own business
everybody's doing their own thing
sat out enjoyed the sun talked to my new
friends from texas and
i had a great time i never saw them
again they went back to texas
after that that's actually when i
decided to
put that i'm a nudist in my dating
profiles so i actually
met someone on one of those apps she
sent me a message hey fellow nudist i'm
one too
and then she actually was the one who
introduced me into the group i joined
the florida young natures
which really opened it up into us so
much more because we have
live music there's the food we have yoga
classes there's
so much to do and i love it i really do
hi i'm ebony and this is the reason why
i became a nudist
my friends their band played at the nude
resort and so i tagged along to be nosey
when i got there i was instantly greeted
by tons of naked people
but they were the most loving people
that i think i'd ever experienced
right off the bat i ended up hanging out
with some people that
noticed that i was almost six foot tall
and they started talking to me about
volleyball
and they educated me on volleyball being
the dominant sport and how they travel
all the time
and asked me if i'd be interested in
coming back to play ball
the next day as nervous as i was i came
home
i talked to my mother just to be sure
i wasn't doing anything that was gonna
upset my family although i wanted to do
it and i wasn't
confident about getting nude but the
volleyball players assured me
they weren't gonna make me be naked so
that i could relax enough to play ball
and before i got out of church the next
day
i had missed several calls from
volleyball players asking me if i was
still coming back
and that they were paying my day fee so
that i could come back and play ball so
i went back and played ball
now i cried the whole 20-minute drive
there because i was scared of being
naked
but i went back and i went back and i
went back
and i cried every drive out there but
every week
i slowly got a little more naked and by
the end of the summer
i showed up for a birthday party of
someone there
and was trying to hype myself up in the
car the whole drive going i'm gonna get
naked today i'm gonna do it today i'm
gonna do it today i'm gonna do it today
and i got in and i parked my car and i
took all my clothes off
and i put this sarong around my waist
and i put the flip-flops on
and as i walked up to the party
there were about 30 people that saw me
coming
and someone screamed oh my god ebony's
finally naked
and the entire group applauded
and i cried because i had struggled so
hard to get there
and they didn't realize the impact that
they had had on me
how beautiful they all were and how
beautiful they wanted me to see
that i was and it wasn't something that
i was ever seeing
so it was it was life-changing they made
me love me
and prior to that i couldn't figure out
if i couldn't love me how could someone
else love me
and now i'm almost 10 years later i'm a
different person
i'm i'm content and happier than i've
ever been in my entire life
you